[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جم وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى تريدنا هذه الصور
بدايه من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم مع
تصاعد المخاوف السياسيه والامنيه
والانسانيه من استمرار الاشتباكات العنيفه
في السودان التي تلقي بظلالها على الوضع
الاقليمي وعلى دول الجوار
ومن واشنطن تحديدا من البيت الابيض هذه
الصور مباشره بعد تحذير الخزانه الامريكيه
من فوضى ماليه وكارثه اقتصاديه امريكيه ما
لم يرفع سقف الدين العام الشهر الحالي
بينما يلتقي الرئيس جو بايدن مع زعماء
الكونجرس لحل الازمه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
مع استمرار المعارك حول مواقع استراتيجيه
في الخرطوم مفاوضات في جده لليوم الثاني
بحضور ممثلين عن الجيش والدعم السريع رئيس
وزن الجيش يقول للجزيره ان التفاوض يدور
حول هدنه انسانيه قصيره لفتح ممرات امنه
وغوتي ريشي وحذر من تحول الصراع في
السودان الى حرب اهليه
تصيد ميداني في اوكرانيا كياف تقول ان
القوات الروسيه كثفت حده القصف على ضخمه
باستخدام اسلحه ثقيله ومتطوره
فاجنر الروسيه تعلن بقائها في جبهات
باخمود بعد وعد بامدادات روسيا تعلن انها
صده هجوما جديدا بمسيرات في شبه جزيره
القرم
وجروسي يحذر من حدث نووي خطير محتمل مع
اخلاء منطقه قريبه من محطه
سباق مع الزمن واتصالات مكثفه بواشنطن
وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه تحذر مما اسمته
فوضى ماليه واقتصاديه وكارثه للنظام
المالي العالمي حال الاخفاق في ابرام
تسويه بشان رفع سقف الدين العام قبل الاول
من يونيو
والجمهوريون يحملون بيض المسؤوليه الازمه
برفضه التفاوض حول اولويات الانفاق
ومستوياته
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا الزخم والحراك الاقليمي في
محاولات لوضع حد للمعارك الدائره في
السودان حيث تستضيف جدا ممثلين من الجيش
والدعم السريع بينما اعرب غوتييرش من اديس
ابابا عن قلقه اذا اتداعيات الازمه
السودانيه على دول الجوار باستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي برايكم ما هي فرص نجاح
المبادرات الاقليميه والدوليه لوقت
المعارف في السودان
21% قالوا انها فرص كبيره بينما
35% اعتبروها فرصا ضئيله اما
44% فقالوا انه لا فرص نهائيا لنجاح هذه
المبادرات
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقاء
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
قبل ايام من التصوير تساؤلات حول طريقه
تعامل الاعلام الغربي مع الانتخابات
التركيه
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل الجزيره في الخرطوم بسماع
اصوات اطلاق نار في المدينه كما افاد
مراسل الجزيره بتجدد الاشتباكات بالاسلحه
الثقيله والخفيفه بين الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع وسط الخرطوم في الاثناء
طائرات حربيه حلقت في سماء الخرطوم
والخرطوم بحري كما سمعت اصوات اسلحه ثقيله
وخفيفه متقطعه في محيط القصر الرئاسي ووسط
الخرطوم
لمتابعه اخر تطورات الوضع الميداني اكان
في ام درمان او حتى في الخرطوم والخرطوم
بحري هيثم
نعم حسن الوضع الميداني ما تزال هذه
المناطق تشهد المواجهات المستمره لهذه
الحرب التي تدخل اسبوعها الرابع او بكل
تداعيات الحرب من ما تحمله من معنى من
خراب ودراء ودمار وسقوط قتلى وجرحى
وتداعيات كذلك سواء كانت انسانيه
واقتصاديه او صحيه او معيشيه هذه
المواجهات اليوم كانت حاضره في محيط
الخرطوم وسط الخرطوم كانت اكثر المناطق
سخونه في ظل وجود اشتباكات
بمحيطه في محيط القصر الرئاسي وايضا وسط
الخرطوم شهدت اعمده الدخان تتصاعد بشكل
كثيف من اكثر من موقع في وسط الخرطوم
ومناطق متفرقه ايضا منطقه بحري ايضا حلق
سلاح الجو التابع للجيش لفترات طويله في
سماء الخرطومه كان يقصف اهدافنا لقوات
الدعم السريع فيما كانت ترد المضادات
الارضيه تابعه للقوات الدعم السريع على
هذه الطائرات هذا كان حال هذا اليوم في
كثير من الاوقات سواء كان في فترات
الصباحيه او الفترات النهاريه وحتى هذه
الفترات المسائيه كانت هناك اصوات كثيفه
لهذه الاصوات المضادات الارضيه وايضا
اصوات القصف والانفجارات التي كانت حاضره
هذه هي الاحداث طبعا تتزامن مع التفاعل
السياسي الجاري حول ما يجري الان من
مفاوضات في جده والانظر كلها تتراقب هناك
داخل السوداني هنا رحب بهذه الخطوه بشكل
كبير وهناك العديد من الاحزاب والكائنات
السياسيه حزب الامه القومي رحب بهذا
الخطوه اعتبرها خطوه مهمه للوصول الى
اتفاق السلام او وخفض التصعيد في اطلاق
النار ايضا
الكيانات الاخرى الحريه والتغيير الكتب
الديمقراطيه والحلول التغيير المجلس
المركزي والعديد من الجهات وان كانت
تتباين في وجهه نظرها حول الحلول السياسيه
لما بعد هذه الخطوه ولكن الكل يجمع في
المرحله الاولى ان يكون هناك وقف لاطلاق
النار على الاقل في هذه المرحله لتمكين
لفتح الممرات الانسانيه وايصال المساعدات
باسرع ما يمكن وبالتالي اتحاد فرصه لما
يمكن ان يتم في المرحله المقبله عقب هذه
الخطوه التي ينتظرها الجميع شكرا لك هيثم
مراسله الجزيره من ام درمان
سياسيا اكد طرف النزاع في السودان
مشاركتهما في محادثات تعقد في مدينه جده
السعوديه هي الاولى منذ اندلاع الازمه وقد
رحبت الرياض واشنطن بالمحادثات الاوليه
بين الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع
واعربت عن املهما في ان تؤدي الى انهاء
النزاع واقل المتحدث باسم الجيش السوداني
العميد نبيل عبد الله ان التفاوض يبحث
اليات تمديد الهدنه ولا يشمل اي اتفاق
نهائيا لوقف اطلاق النار او قضايا سياسيه
ودعا وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري طرفي
الازمه في السودان الى العوده للحوار
السياسي وقال في اجتماع لمجلس الجامعه
العربيه على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه العرب
انه يتعين وقف اطلاق النار في السودان
وضمان الالتزام به
بدورها اكدت الهيئه الحكوميه الدوليه
للتنميه ايجاد انها تتابع عن كسب محادثات
وقت اطلاق النار بين ممثلي الجيش السوداني
وقوه الدعم السريع التي بدات في جده وحفت
الجانبين على اغتنام فرصه المحادثات وجها
لوجه لاسكات البنادق ودعت منظمه ايجاد
الطرفين الى الموافقه الفوريه وغير
المشروطه على وقف اطلاق النار لاسباب
انسانيه مشيره الى ان ذلك من شانه السماح
للسكان المدنيين والعائلات بالوصول الى
الحمايه والممرات الامنه للتنقل وخدمات
الرعايه الصحيه وتلبيه احتياجاتهم
الغذائيه وكانت منظمه ايجاد قد بدات
مبادره للوساطه بين طرفي النزاع بارسالها
بعثه سلام رفيعه المستوى تضم رؤساء جنوب
السودان وكينيا وجيبوتي الى الخرطوم لحث
الطرفين على وقف اطلاق النار
ينضم الينا من جده مراسل الجزيره بدر
الربيعان بدر الى اين وصلت هذه المحادثات
بين الطرفين السودانيين وهل رشح شيئا او
شيء حولها
نعم حسن حتى اللحظه لم يصدر اي بيان على
جانب السعودي ممثلا بوزاره الخارجيه او اي
تصريحات من اطراف عمليه المفاوضات بهذا
الخصوص بالواضح انه ما يجري حاليا في جده
هو نوع من المباحثات يسعى روعات
والسعوديون الامريكيون من اجل ترقيتها الى
مرحله المفاوضات الجاده نتحدث عن الجوله
الثانيه من المباحثات بين طرفي النزاع
السوداني والتي انطلقت يوم امس لا يوجد
سقف زمني محدد لهذه المباحثات الاوليه
والتي تجري بشكل غير مباشر وتناقش ملفات
تمديد الهدنه وايضا مدى التزام الطرفين
بها اضافه لتوفير ممرات امنه للوصول
للمساعدات لمناطق المتضرره رئيس وفد
التفاوض بالجيش السوداني اللواء ابو بكر
فقيري قال ان المفاوضات غير المباشره ما
زالت مستمره في نفي غير مباشر للمعلومات
التي تحدثت عن انسحاب اطراف النزاع اكد
ايضا ان ما يتم البحث عن حاليا هو هدنه
انسانيه قصيره لفتح ممرات امنه للمساعدات
الانسانيه لرفع المعاناه على
المدنيين الجيش سوداني ياتي الى طاوله
المباحثات في جده بمواقف معلنه وثابته هي
تثبيت الهدن الالتزام بها ومدى جديه قوات
الدعم السريع في وقف اطلاق النار وفتح
ممرات انسانيه امنه اضافه الى تامين
عمليات الاجلاء هذه المباحثات التجريبي
وساطه سعوديه امريكيه بحضور مبعوثه الامم
للسوداني اضافه الى ممثلين الرباعيه
الدوليه وجاءت ايضا نتيجه جهد دبلوماسي
سعودي امريكي بهدف وقف الحرب المدلعه منذ
ثلاثه اسابيع والعوده الى العمليه
التفاوضيه والمباحثات التي تجري هنا في
جده حتى الان لم تحصل مفاوضات مباشره بين
الطرفين هي مفاوضات غير مباشره اي ان
الوفدين لم يلتقيا لوجه
نعم حسن حتى اللحظه لم يرشح اي معلومات
بهذا الخصوص محادثات مباشره بين طرفي
النزاع هنا عمليه المباحثات التجريه
بواساطه ورعايه سعوديه امريكيه تبحث عن
رسم خارطه الطريق للمباحثات لوقف العمليات
العسكريه وايضا حث على ضمان اصول
المساعدات اذا ما تحدثنا عن رعايه راعي
المباحثات لتجريه الان السعوديه وامريكا
يملكون اوراق اوراق تاثير على الطرفين
بالتاكيد سوف يدخلون في مرحله تقديم
اقتراحات وحلول خلال الايام المقبله بشكل
الاكبر بحكم الجلوس مع الطرفين والسماعه
ايضا لما يقدمونهم معلومات ومولود
تفاوضضيه بهذا الخصوص السعوديه هنا يؤكدون
على اهميه وقف التصعيد العسكري بين
الاطراف المتنازع وانهاء العنف حتى اللحظه
حقيقه لا يوجد اي معلومات عن مسار هذه
العمليه العمليه للتجري في وزاره الخارجيه
هنا في جده شكرا لك بدر ربيعان مراسله
الجزيره من جده
حذر الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيرش من تحول الصراع في السودان الى حرب
اهليه وقال غوتيرش اثناء زيارته لدوله
الكونغو الديمقراطيه انه يجب ان يتوقف
القتال على الفور قبل ان يتحول هذا الصراع
الى حرب اهليه يمكن ان تدمر البلاد وتعطل
المنطقه لسنوات قادمه مشددا على ضروره عمل
جميع الاطراف على نزع فتيل التوترات
والجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات والاتفاق على
وقف اطلاق نار مستقر ودائم
اعين الجميع نحو جده السعوديه تزامنا مع
تواصل عمليات الاجلاء عبر مينائها يجري
طرف الصراع في السودان محادثات لاول مره
ترحب الرياض واشنطن وتعربان عن الامل في
الوصول لنهايه النزاع يحدد الجيش السوداني
شكل هذه المحادثات يقول ان الجلسات تبحث
فقط اليات تمديد الهدنه ولا تشمل اي اتفاق
نهائي لوقف اطلاق النار او قضايا سياسيه
اعين الاتحاد الافريقي على جده كذلك يقدم
الاتحاد الازمه الانسانيه امام الطرفين
داعيا لوقف القتال على وجه السرعه يتحرك
الامين العام للامم المتحده يصل الى
العاصمه الاثيوبيه ويلتقي رئيس الوزراء
ورئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي يكشف مصدر
للجزيره ان الامم المتحده والاتحاد
الافريقي سيقدمان خارطه طريق لانهاء
الازمه
من اديس ابابا عن قلقه من تداعيات الاوضاع
في السودان على المنطقه وخاصه دول الجوار
يصف بوتيرج هذه الدول بالهشه وتلك الدول
تستقبل وتصدر اللاجئين بالملايين بسبب
ازماتها الداخليه امنيا وغذائيا اذ يستقبل
السودان اكثر من مليون لاجئ هربوا اليه من
دول الجوار اثيوبيا وجنوب السودان تحديدا
اصبح السودان الان يصدر اللاجئين الى هذه
الدول ما يزيد من الازمه الانسانيه في
المنطقه ككل تتاثر مصر فيتحرك وزير
خارجيتها في جوله اقليميه كذلك ولكن بعد
ثلاثه اسابيع يتوجه سامح شكري الى تشاد
وجنوب السودان يبحث فيهما عن حل للازمه هو
الاخر استقبلت مصر عشرات الالاف من
اللاجئين السودانيين خلال الاسابيع قليله
الماضيه المسؤولون المصريون قلقون على
اقتصادهم المعتمد بشكل كبير على السودان
في لمحه سريعه على الامر يشكل التبادل
التجاري بين مصر والسودان اكثر من 13% من
التبادل التجاري المصري مع افريقيا مجتمعه
رقم كبير يعكس الاعتماد المصريه على جواره
الجنوبي لا سيما في الامن الغذائي اما
الامن بمفهومه التقليدي فيؤرق القاهره وهي
تراقب حدودا تتجاوز 1200 كم قد تفتح على
مصرعيها اذا انهار النظام الامي في
السودان بسبب القتال التحركات الاخيره
تاتي بعد تحركات اقليميه اخرى لم تفضي الى
نتائج عمليه طرحت منظمه الايجاد الافريقيه
مبادره للحل وقررت افاده رؤساء كينيا
وجنوب السودان وجيبوتي بحثا عن ذلك الحل
التزمنا ذلك مع استعداد من جنوب السودان
لاستضافه طرفي السرعه لكن كل ذلك مره دون
اثر لذلك يترقب الجميع محادثات جده
السودانيون ليسوا وحدهم
من ينتظر نهايه هذه الازمه
[موسيقى]
السيطره لديه
كما هو واضح ضرب
واصبحت القوات ليس عند ما في اي كنترول
عليها من من القياده يعني القياده مراكز
القياده والسيطره ضربت ولذلك من الصعوب
الحديث عن هدنه نحن في الهدنه السابعه
ولما يعني يحدث ان التزم كل اي من الطلبين
بالهدنه لانه هناك يعني جهه لا احد يسيطر
عليها الان يعني تتوقع نجاحا لهذه
المفاوضات باختصار
انا لا اتوقع نجاحا ولا اتوقع هدنه الا ان
تتضح الموازين القوى في الميدان طيب كان
لافت كلام جوتيريش من انه يخشى من ان
يتحول هذا الصراع الى حرب اهليه تدمر
المنطقه او بالاحرى تعطل المنطقه لسنوات
قادمه برايك
ما سبب هذه الخشيه لدى غوتييرش انا اعترض
هنالك تحويل اكبر من اللازم لهذا الموضوع
الحرب الاهليه الان السودان من 18 ولايه
وهنالك 16 ولايه ليس فيها حرب وهذه كلها
من الحرب ولذلك لا اعتقد الان نحن نتحدث
الان ليس هنالك الخرطوم ودرفور ليس هنالك
حتى في دارفور منطقه معدوده جدا هي منطقه
الجنينه ولذلك ليت هنالك مؤشرات حقيقيه
لغير الحرب الاهليه الحرب الاهليه تحتاج
يعني عناصر
الان نحن نتحدث عن تمرد محدود لمجموعه
الدعم السريع من القوات المسلحه ويجد
التعامل معها ولكن انا لا ارى مؤشرات الان
تؤشر الى يمكن اتساع هذا الامر الى يهدد
السلم الاقليمي او العالمي هو ينشر حرب
اهليه كل ذلك
مبادره الايجاد اين اصبحت مبادره عليها
شكوك كثيره جدا
واضح لي ان الجيش يتحفظ عليها بسبب موقف
كينيا من النظام
والكثير من التصريحات غير الايجابيه في حق
الجيش
والنظام الكيني يعتبر الكفه يعني متساويه
بين الجيش وبين الدعم السريع وهذا لم
ترضاه بالجيش ولذلك تحفظت على المبادره
الكنيه مبادره الايجاد وذهبت في اتجاه
مبادره الامريكيه السعوديه شكرا لك الكاتب
والمحلله السياسي السوداني
الى تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث قالت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انه تمت السيطره على
منطقتين اخرىين في بخموت بدعم من القوات
المحموله جوا وفي وقت سابق الاحد اعلن
مالك شركه فاغنري افقي
قرارا رسميا بامداد قوته في بكل ما تحتاجه
من ذخائر وذلك بعد تهديده باحتمال تسليمه
الجبهه لقوات شيشانيه بسبب نقص الذخائر من
جانب قل الجيش الاوكراني ان الوضع في
الجبهه الشرقيه في المنطقه يشهد توترا
لكنه تحت السيطره وان الخطه تقضي باستمرار
الدفاع عن باخموت للحاق اقصى ضرر بالجانب
الروسي
توشك بخموت ام تصبح ركاما لكن ذلك لا يدرء
عنها القذائف والصواريخ لتظل المدينه
المنكوبه في مرمى هجمات الروس ودفاعات
الاوكرانيين في ان
وقد تلقت المدينه مزيدا من الاخبار السيئه
اذا اكد رئيس مجموعه فاجنر يفغيني ريغوجين
ان قواته باقيه هناك بعد ان تلقى وعدا من
الجيش الروسي بتزويد تلك القوات بالاسلحه
والذخائر اللازمه ومنحها صلاحيه التصرف
والتحرك في بخموت بناء على ظروف المعركه
ويضع هذا الاعلان حدا لتهديدات يوم الجمعه
الماضي التي لوح فيها بسحب مقاتله من
المدينه في حال لم يتلقوا احتياجاتهم من
الذخيره عشيه احتفالات موسكو بالانتصار
على النازيين ارجح الجيش الاوكراني اشتداد
الهجوم على بخموت لكنه اكد استمرار جنوده
في الدفاع عن المدينه
المختلف على قيمتها الفعليه عسكريا
واستراتيجيا
في تجايس لدار مخموت لشبكه وحده صواريخ
تابعه لنا كتيبه من اللواء الرابع
والخمسين الاوكراني واصطدمت مستودعا
للذخيره ومنطقه انتشار مؤقته لقوات
اوكرانيه
بعيدا عن تلك الجبهه لا تهدو اله الحرب
ايضا حاكم خرسون الاوكراني اعلن سقوط
مدنيين قتله في قصف روسي استهدف مناطق
ماهوله وشبكات للبنيه التحتيه
وفي مدينه نيوكوبولو التابعه لمقاطعه
دينيبرو والمطله على
النوويه قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه ان قصفا
روسيا استهدف مناطق ماهوله بالسكان وادى
الى مقتل واصابه مدنيين فضلا عن الحاق
اضرار
بانابيب للغاز وخطوط للكهرباء
ويتزايد القلق من خطر احتدام القتال في
تلك المنطقه لقربها من المحطه النوويه
وفيما يبدو تصميما من كييف على توسيع نطاق
المعركه تعهد الجيش الاوكراني بتحويل شبه
جزيره القرم الى جبهه مواجهه ساخنه مع
الروس
افتتالت هجمات الطائرات المسيره على اهداف
لا سيما في مدينه سيفاستوبول وهو ما اكده
حاكمها الروسي وقرت به
المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه واصفه الهجمات بانها مجرد
بدايه
الينا من موسكو كونستانتيني بلوخين الباحث
في مركز ابحاث الامن بموسكو ومن بنسلفانيا
مايكل
نائب مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق
لشؤون الناتو وابدا معك سيد قسطنطين هل
تضع موسكو هدف السيطره على بخموت فعلا قبل
التاسع من الجاري
نعم
هذه ليست اوهام ان باخم تقريبا محرر من
القوات الاوكرانيه بنسبه 90 بالمئه
وفي يوم عيد النصر على الفاشيه اعتقد ان
هذا سيكون شيء مهم جدا النصر لروسيا
ولبوتين بشكل خاص ورد جيد
بالمناسبه على الهجمات
بالمسيرات الاوكرانيه التي منذ فتره قريبه
هاجمت عدا عن ذلك السيطره على بخمس ستسمح
وتفتح امكانيات
لصد الهجمات العكسيه الاوكرانيه اذا بدات
قسنطينه عفوا
عذرا فقط طيب اذا كان هذا هو الهدف اذا
كان هذا هو الهدف لماذا لا تعطى الامدادات
لفاجنر او كان روسيا تخشى ان يكون هذا
الانجاز لصالح فاجنر لا تقدم لها امدادات
عسكريه الا بعد تهديدات علنيه
شديده من مالك هذه المؤسسه لماذا
اعتقد ان هذه مساله البيروقراطيه
بناء السياسي الداخلي الذي نراه في
التاريخ الروسي الحديث وزاره الدفاع ليست
شيء مختلف البرقاطيه موجود في كل مكان
الشيء الثاني النداع بين وزاره الدفاع
وشركه فاقنر هي التنافس بين بينهم
والتنافس موجود في كل مكان ايضا في
الولايات المتحده بين المخابرات وقوه
الامن وبين فاجنر ووزاره
الدفاع هذا الشيء موجود بعض الخبراء
يعتقدون ان انه بعد الانتهاء من العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه ان بريجوجين راس
فاقدر لديه فرصه ان يصبح
شخصيه سياسيه نافذه في روسيا لانه لديه
قدره وشخصيه ملهمه والكثيرين من
المتطرفين يدعموه خاصه من يقف مع الحكومه
في الموقف من اوكرانيا خاصه ان روسيا لا
تستخدم كل القدرات التي لديها في العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه ولذلك
هو احد المتطرفين الذين يقومون باعلى
الدرجات من التعامل الصعب فهذه المشكله مع
الذخيره سوف تحل بالمستقبل القريب وسوف
يحصل على القذائف والذخيره وسوف يطور
هجماته ونجاحه في هذا الاتجاه
لعدا عن ذلك
انتقل هنا الى السيد مايكل ريان من
بنسلفانيا سيد مايكل
يعني في الوقت الذي يتم الحديث عن الهجوم
المضاد وعن مساعدات ومطالبات غربيه
وامريكيه لبدء هذا الهجوم
المضاد ها هي القوات الروسيه وقوات فاجنر
تتقدم وتسيطر على منطقتين اضافيتين من
باخمد كيف تقيم الوضع العسكري الذي ما
زالت فيه القوات الاوكرانيه تخسر مناطق في
الجبهه الشرقيه
شكرا على السؤال سؤالك للضيف الاخر كان
مهما جدا ما هي رمزيه باخ موت بالتالي كيف
يمكننا ان نفسر اي تقدم قد تحرزه القوات
الروسيه
باقتراب احتفالات النصر في التاسع من مايو
الرئيس
بوتين هو ايضا في منافسه مع رئيس فاغنر
وهو في حرب مع اوكرانيا حرب بداها رمزيه
بخ موت لكي تعطي الرئيس بوتين لا يمكن
التاكيد عليها بشكل كبير بالتالي
الاوكرانيين حول استعادتها وروسيا قد فقدت
خسائر كبيره في محاولتها ابقاء سيطرتها
على ابا بالتالي
يجب ان يكون هنالك عليهم ان يدعموا السيد
بريكوجن وان يقوموا بتقديم المعدات التي
يحتاجها في الوقت الذي يكون هنالك مواجهه
كامله مع القوات الاوكرانيه الامر الذي قد
يكون يمثل هجمه مضاده كما ذكرت ان هنالك
دعم من القوات الاوكرانيه من الكثير من
الدول الغربيه ولكن انا يبقى سؤالي متعلق
بما ستقوم به القوات الاوكرانيه في
المقابل برايك ما الذي يعنيه الهجوم
بالمسيرات الهجوم المكثف بالمسيرات على
شبه جزيره القرم
نعم
ان القدره اوكرانيا على مواجهه القوات
الروسيه ودفع القوات الروسيه هي نفس القرن
القرم هو هي جائزه سرقها الروس في عام
2014 وهم
يستثمرون الكثير من الامكانيات الدفاعيه
هناك وهم يحاولون وكلما حاولوا عمل الروس
ان يدافعوا عن القرن فانهم يعرضون قواتهم
في الاماكن الاخرى الى مواقع ضعف بالتالي
هنالك نوع من التحييد لقوه روسيا في اماكن
اخرى
بالوقت الذي تقول في روسيا انها تتقدم في
باخموت هي تخشى فعلا من الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد لا سيما في الجنوب وهي تقوم باخلاء
المدنيين
والمتعاونين معها من مناطق الجنوب تحديدا
في خرسون
لماذا
الواقع روسيا لا تخشى الهجمات العكسيه
روسيا تحضر لهذه الهجمات وفي الواقع
اوكرانيا والغرب لديهم حالتين لتطوير
الاحداث الاول بعد الهجمات العكسيه
الاوكرانيه من الممكن او عفوا الامكانيات
الاوكرانيه سوف تصبح تقريبا صفر وهذا يعني
ان مستقبل الدوله الاوكرانيه سيكون معتمد
على السياسه الروسيه والشيء الوحيد الذي
ممكن الشيء الوحيد الذي سوف
تتمكن منه اوكرانيا والغرب هو المفاوضات
مع روسيا مع بعد عفوا الهجمات العكسيه
المنتظره الشيء الثاني
بامكانهم ان لا يخاطروا وان لا يستخدموا
كل الامكانيات في الهجمات العكسيه بل على
العكس الحفاظ على هذه الامك انيات
وتشكيل
قلعه اوكرانيه
لكي يتحول عن نزاع الاوكراني لافغانستان
الثانيه وفي الواقع
نحن في كل اللقاءات الاخباريه نناقش
هذه الهجمات العكسيه الاوكرانيه منذ اشهر
ولكن من وجهه نظر العقل والمنطق لو كانت
اوكرانيا تريد ان تنظم هذه الهجمات
العكسيه كان عليها ان تخفي
الاخبار عن هذا في السريه التامه وان لا
تتحدث وتعلن عن هذا في العالم كله وفي كل
الاخبار وهذا يعني ان الهدف الاوكراني
ليست الهجمات العكسيه
ان يحصلوا على تمويل وهذه نقطه مهمه السيد
عذرا هذه النقطه مهمه سيد مايكل الم
بالحديث عن الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد الم
يفقد
عامل المفاجاه سيد مايكل هذا الهجوم
المضاد الم
يفقد فعاليه ما او جزءا من فعاليته
بفقدانه عامل المفاجاه خصوصا
وان اصوات اوكرانيه بدات تقول ان التوقعات
الغربيه من هذا الهجوم قد يكون مبالغ بها
نعم
الهجمه المضاده الاوكرانيه ستاتي بشكل
حتمي كل النقاشات المحيطه بوقتها ومكان
هذا الامر يتعلق بالاوكرانيين ولصالح
الاوكرانيه لان الروس عليهم ان يدافعوا
على جبهه طويله ايضا الضعف الاخر بالنسبه
للروس ان هنالك دعم متزايد
هنالك قله ضعف الدعم الشعبي للحرب ان
هذا الاستعراض في يوم الاحتفال في يوم
النصر يقترحوا ان الحرب لا تسير بشكل جيد
وان روسيا تشعر بالضعف هذا ايضا في صالح
الهجمه المضاده بالتالي راينا الكرملين
والرئيس بوتين يحاول ان
يقلل من التوقعات لانتصار مبكر وايضا يقلل
من اهميه النصر الذي قد يحرزه الاوكرانيين
بالتالي هنالك الكثير من العناصر التي
مؤثره هنالك الراي العام في روسيا وعدد
الناس الذين
يستمرون بدعم هذا الجهد الحربي في روسيا
وايضا توقع النصر الذي قد تحرزه اوكرانيا
يعتقد ان المستقبل يحمل في طياته الكثير
من المفاجات لكن ريان من بنسلفن يا مساعد
وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق لشؤون الناتو
شكرا
لك وشكرا
لكونستانتين بلوخين الباحث في مركزي ابحاث
الامن بموسكو
عشيه محادثات حاسمه بين الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن وزعماء الجمهوريين بشان رفع سقف
الدين العام قالت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه
جانيتيالين ان عدم رفع سقط الدين العام
سيتسبب في عدم قدره الولايات المتحده على
تسديد ديونها واضافت في لقاء مع محطه
تلفزيون اي بي سي ان فشل الكونجرس في رفع
سقف الدين الامريكي بحلول الاول من يونيو
سيحدث عواقب اقتصاديه في السوق الماليه
اذا لم يرفع سقف الدين فستجد وزاره
الخزانه نفسها في وضع لا يمكن فيه دفع
مستحقاتنا في الاول من يونيو وستكون هذه
المره الاولى في تاريخ الولايات المتحده
التي نفشل فيها في سداد المدفوعات
المستحقه وهذا سيتسبب بفوضى ماليه
واقتصاديه حيث ان سنادات الخزانه
الامريكيه هي الاكثر امانا في النظام
المالي العالمي واخفاق الولايات المتحده
في سداد ديونها من شانه ان يثير التساؤل
عن اهليتنا الائتمانيه من المحتمل ان نرى
عواقب اقتصاديه في السوق الماليه اذا لم
يتحرك الكونغرس سريعا
ومع استمرار تماسك رئيس الكونجرس الجمهوري
بخفض الميزانيه قبل الوصول الى ايه اتفاق
قال رئيس لجنه الخدمات الماليه بمجلس
النواب الامريكي النائب الجمهوري باتريك
ماتشينري ان قرار رفيع سقف الدين العام
يتعلق بمجلس الشيوخ ذي الاغلبيه
الديمقراطيه وليس النواب للاغلبيه
الجمهوريه واضاف ماشينري في لقاء مع محطه
سي بي اس الاخباريه الامريكيه ان الرئيس
جو بايدن بحاجه الى حل توافقي ينهي ازمه
الدين العام في الولايات المتحده
تعاملنا في مجلس النواب مع ملفات النمو
والانفاق الفوري والمدخرات طويله الاجل
بشكل متوازن ضمن خطتنا ورفعناه الى مجلس
الشيوخ الرئيس قال لنا ارونا خطتكم لقد
فعلنا لم نكشف خطتنا فقط بل مررناها ايضا
بمجلس النواب لكن مجلس الشيوخ لم يمررها
لان هناك ثلاثه واربعين عضوا يقولون انهم
لا يوافقوا على خطه الشمر الان يتعين على
الرئيس ان ياتي الى الطاوله للتوصل الى حل
تفاوضى عليه ان يستمع لمستشاره
الاقتصاديين لاسياسيين
وفي التطور الاحداث للسجال بشان ازمه سقف
الدين العام قال البيت الابيض ان طلب
الجمهوريين تطليس مليارات من تمويل
الاعمال التجاريه الحيويه قد يعرقلوا سداد
الدين الامريكي
على شفا ازمه ماليه غير مسبوقه تجد
الولايات المتحده نفسها بعد تاكيد وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه جانتيلين استنفاذ كل
التدابير الاستثنائيه خلال الاشهر القليله
الماضيه لتلاف تبعات وصول البلاد الى حد
الدين القانوني البالغي واحدا وثلاثين
تريليونا و400 مليار دولار وفشل الكونغرس
حتى الان في التوصل لاتفاق بشان رفع سقف
الدين ما يعني عجز الولايات المتحده لاول
مره في التاريخ عن الوفاء بالتزاماتها
الماليه والتخلف عن سداد ديونها وقد يتسبب
ذلك في ضرر لا يمكن اصلاحه للاقتصاد
الامريكي وسبل عيش جميع الامريكيين
والاستقرار المالي العالمي كما سبق وحذرت
وزيره الخزانه قبل عده اسابيع لكن كيف وصل
الحال في الولايات المتحده الى هذا
السيناريو الكارثي رغم نذره منذ مطلع
العام الحالي القصه بدات عندما قرر
الكونجرس الامريكي عام
1917 وضع اجراء تم بموجبه تحديد السقف
الاقصى الذي يمكن للحكومه استدانته وذلك
لتغطيه العجز بين ايراداتها ونفقاتها لكي
تتمكن من تامين الاموال اللازمه لرواتب
الموظفين والعسكريين وشكات الضمان
الاجتماعي وخدمات الرعايه الصحيه وغيرها
من اوجه النفقات الحكوميه ويتم ذلك اي
اقتراض الحكومه للاموال عبر طرح السندات
الحكوميه التي ينظر لها عالميا على انها
استثمار امن وموثوق وتحتاج الحكومه في حال
الوصول الى سقف الدين العام الى موافقه
الكونجرس اي مجلسي النواب والشيوخ لرفعه
مجددا وحتى اليوم يرفض الجمهوريون الذين
يسيطرون على مجلس النواب الموافقه على هذه
الخطوه ويشترطون اجراء تخفيضات في
الميزانيه الحكوميه الامر الذي ترفضه
اداره بايدن وتتهم خصومها في الكونجرس
باخذ الاقتصاد الامريكي رهينه في ايديهم
لدفعها للقيام باقتطاعات جائره من
الميزانيه وفي حال عجز الطرفين عن التوصل
للاتفاق قبل يونيو القادم فان اسواق المال
الامريكيه والعالميه مهدده بالتعرض لخسائر
فادحه فضلا عن فقدان النظام المالي
الامريكي لموثوقيته الدوليه واستوقعات بان
يدخل الاقتصاد الامريكي فخر كود وان يفقد
سوق العمل الامريكي اكثر من سته ملايين
فرصه عمل ما يعني ارتفاع معدلات البطاله
بشكل قياسي
ينضم الينا من نيويورك استاذه الاقتصاد
السياسي الدكتور
ريمي
دكتور ريمي ربما ليست المره الاولى التي
تحدث هذه الازمه لكن هل يمكن ان تكون
المره الاولى التي تتخلف فعلا الولايات
المتحده عن سداد ديونها
لحظه
متوتره وبالتاكيد تم التركيز على نتيجه
انتخابات السنه القادمه لدينا الكثير من
الاطراف بين مكارتي رئيس
القائد الاغلبيه وايضا بالبيت الابيض
وهنالك تركيز على مساله اداره الميزانيه
هي امكانيه يمتلكها جمهوريا وان الرئيس لا
يقوم باداره الاقتصاد بشكل صحيح عندما
ننظر الى الوضع نحن نتحدث فقط عن زياده
سقف الدين لميزانها تم التوافق عليها
السنه الماضيه وبالتاكيد وبجود اغلبيه
ديموقراطيه في الكونجرس بالتالي تم
التوافق على شيء وسيكون ذلك رفع لسقف
الديون وهذا حدث
87 بالمره فقط بالتالي الامر ليس غير
معتاد لكن باقتراب الانتخابات السنه
القادمه وبايضا بوجود الصراع السياسي في
واشنطن نعم هنالك محاوله من قبل الحزب
الجمهوري من اجل اجباري اداره باي على ان
ربما قد يصل الى مساله العجز عن سداد
الديون نعم
هذا الامر مفهوم لكن هل يلعب الجمهوريون
على حافه الهاويه ام فعلا
يمكن ان تتخلى في الولايات المتحده عن
سداد الديون وماذا بعد
يلعبون لعبه حافه الهاويه هنالك مقترح
سيتم تمريره عبر الكونجرس خلال الاسابيع
القادمه الابرز يطلب ايضا استقطاعات كبيره
في الميزانيه من اجل رفع سقف الديون
والموافقه عليها هذا القانون ربما سيمد
توقيع عليه من قبل الحزب الجمهوري لكنه
سيتم رفضه من قبل مجلس الشيوخ لكنه سيسمح
لمكارتي انه يعطيه شعورا
بالمسؤوليه وان
الداره الديمقراطيه هي ليست قادره على
اداره الميزانيه لكنها لعبه سياسيه فقط
ستحصل حتى الايام الاخيره في شهر مايو في
نهايه المطاف ربما ستضع الاسواق الماليه
في وضع غير مريح وبوجود تبعات محتمله
بالتالي اللعبه السياسيه في واشنطن سيكون
ربما تبعات محتمله على التوقعات وعلى سوق
الاسهم مستقبلا من المحتمل ان سقف الدين
سيتم برفعه وهنالك طريقه لاداره بايدن لكي
تقوم بتمرير هذا الامر بدون الكونجرس عن
طريق التعديل الرابع عشر للدستور لكن هذا
الامر لم يتم استخدامه في السابق دكتور
الاستاذه الاقتصاد السياسي
من نيويورك شكرا جزيلا لك
الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله حيث
اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه بلده
اليامون غرب جنين وحصلت منزلا في البلده
واندلعت اشتباكات مع مقومين فلسطينيين ما
اجبر جنود الاحتلال على الانسحاب من
المكان واشنت قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
ليله الماضيه وفجر اليوم حمله دهم وتفتيش
في مناطق مختلفه بالضفه الغربيه تخللتها
مواجهات في منطقتين نابلس وجنين
كما هدمت قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فجرا
اليوم مدرسه التحدي خمسه الاساسيه في قريه
جب الذيب شرقي مدينه بيت لحم بالضفه
الغربيه
وافاد حسن
بريجيه مدير هيئه شؤون مقاومه الجدار
والاستيطان في بيت لحم ان محكمه الاحتلال
قررت هدمه القريه قبل اسبوعين بناء على
طلب من منظمه ريجافيم الصهيونيه بسبب
اعاقته مخططاتهم الاستيطانيه في المنطقه
بدوره طالبه الاتحاد الاوروبي سلطات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه بوقف جميع عمليات
هدم منازل الفلسطينيين والتخلي عن سياسه
اجلائهم من مناطقهم مشيرا الى انها تؤدي
الى زياده معاناتهم وتصعيد حاله التوتر
القائمه واعرب الاتحاد الاوروبي في بيان
صحفي عن صدمته من هدم سلطات الاحتلال
مدرسه التحدي خمسه في منطقه جيب الديب
شرقي مدينه بيت لحم المموله من الاتحاد
واكد البيان ان عمليات الهدم غير قانونيه
بموجب القانون الدولي مشددا على احترام حق
الاطفال الفلسطينيين في التعليم
في ظل ارتفاع وتيره اقتحامات القوات
الاسرائيليه للمدن الفلسطينيه تبث الجزيره
مساء الاثنين حلقه خاصه من برنامج للقصه
بقيه الذي تقدم الزميل فيروز زياني تتضمن
تحقيقا ليكشف الاستراتيجيات العسكريه
والاستخباراتيه التي تتبعها وحده
المستعربين خلال اقتحاماتها في الضفه
الغربيه ويوثق البرنامج شهاده حصريه لاحد
العناصر السابقين في وحده المستعربين عن
تفاصيل عمل الوحده ودورها في الاقتحامات
كما يكشف التحقيق بالمحاكاه الهندسيه
اليات الاقتحام والمراحل التي تمر بها
ويوثق استخدام الاطفال الفلسطينيين كدروع
بشريه خلال اقتحامات القوات الخاصه
الاسرائيليه برنامج للقصه باقيه التي
تقدمها الزميله فيروز زياني يعرض الاثنين
في 10:05 بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
الان مشاهدينا الى تغطيهنا الخاصه لمشهد
الانتخابات في تركيا
معظم زعماء تحالف الشعب المعارض في تركيا
مهرجان
انتخابيه في مدينه اسطنبول مع اقتراب
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والتشريعيه المقرره
في الرابع عشر من الشهر الجاري
وانقذوا التحالف الشعب المكون من احزاب
الشعب الجمهوري والجيد والمستقبل والسعاده
ودواء والديمقراطي خطبه في حشود قدرها
المراقبون بعشرات الالاف للتصويت لصالح
التحالف خلال الانتخابات المقبله
هذا ودع زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري المعارض
في تركيا كمال
المواطنين للتصويت لصالح ما وصفه بالحق
والعداله والوقوف في وجه من يهدد
المواطنين حسب تعبيره جاء ذلك خلال كلمه
القاها
في حشد جماهري في مدينه كرشهير وسط البلاد
ستتوجهون الى صناديق الاقتراع وستصوتون
لصالح الحق والعداله ولصالح المواطن
وستقفون في وجه من يتحدث معكم باستعلاء
ومن يهددكم لقد تولوا الحكم لمده 22 عاما
كفى وليتنحوا جانبا لتحقيق التغيير
وليتولى مكانهم انسان عادل لا يغتصب حقوق
العباد
قال الرئيس التركي والمرشح الرئاسي عن
تحالف الجمهور رجال الطيب اردوغان انه لا
يمكن ان يكون لدى المعارضه هدف كالحفاظ
على وحده البلاد وشعبها واتهم اردوغان في
كلمه له خلال مهرجان الانتخابي باسطنبول
اتهم المعارضه بالعمل مع من وصفهم
بالارهابيين ومن يهدف لضرب اقتصاد تركيا
الذي يعمل مع التنظيمات الارهابيه
بالتقسيم بلدنا اليست واضحه رسائل من
تعاون مع الارهابيين لنقل حلقه النار
والدماء التي دمرت سوريا الى تركيا وليست
واضحه رسائل من دعم مخططات مستغلي
الاقتصاد ومساعهم في افلاس تركيا
واليست واضحه رسائل من انزعج من الغاز
الذي اكتشفناه في البحر الاسود ومن النفط
الذي اكتشفناه في جبل جابا واسالكم انتم
هل يمكن ان يكون لهؤلاء هدف كالحفاظ على
وحده بلدنا وشعبنا وقوه بلدنا وبقائه
مشهد التنافس الانتخابي في تركيا يترافق
مع كثير من التعليقات على واجهات الصحف
الغربيه وقد سلطت الكثير من وسائل الاعلام
الغربيه الضوء على مجريات الحدث الانتخابي
لكن بعضها اعتمدت اساليب في التغطيه تطرح
اكثر من سؤال المزيد في تقرير نسيبه موسى
تتصدر تركيا عناوين وسائل الاعلام الغربيه
تهتم بشكل واضح بما يبدو صراعا حاسما بين
مشروعين العداله والتنميه مقابل المشروع
الذي يوحد المعارضه بمختلف تشكيلاتها تقدم
معظمها لجمهورها صوره عن حاله استقطاب في
الشارع السياسي التركي وتمعن اخرى في وضع
كشف حساب لسنوات حكم العداله والتنميه
ورصد الازمات والاخفاقات وان حافظت بعض
وسائل الاعلام على قدر يسير من الحياد في
تغطيتها رهانات الانتخابات التركيه فان
اخرى وتحديدا صحفا بارزه تكاد تتشابه في
عناوين تهيمن عليها شخصنه الحدث بالتركيز
فقط على الرئيس اردوغان فيما يشبه حمله
تتواتر فيها المواد والعناوين والصور
الملتقى
بتتبع ما تنشره وسائل الاعلام الغربيه
فان اردوغان يتفوق على غيره من الساسه او
رؤساء الحكومات او حتى الرؤساء السابقين
في تركيا بكونه ماده دسمه شخصيته بل غالبا
لرسم صوره نمطيه وحتى السخريه منه
هذه افتتاحيه واشنطن بوست الامريكيه ترى
الصحيفه ان شبح الاستبداد يخيم على
الانتخابات التركيه اذا فاز اردوغان
بولايه جديده وتتحدث عن رئيس تصفه
بالمستبد الديكتاتور الذي يقطن قصرا
مبهرجا من الف غرفه مقابل كمال كلشتار
اوغلو الموظف البسيط الذي سيعيد توحيد
تركيا لكن البريطانيه كانت اكثر حده
بقولها ان اردوغان يجب ان يرحل وان على
الاتراك التصويت لانقاذ الديمقراطيه اما
مجله درش بيجل الالمانيه فعنوانات غلافها
باردوغان الفوضى او الانقسام في اشاره الى
منعطفات خطيره قد تشهدها تركيا بعد
انتخابات الرابع عشر من مايو جاري وارفقته
بصوره مركبه للرئيس التركي يظهر خلفه
الهلال العثماني ورمز الدوله التركيه
مكسورا اما مجله بروفيل النمساويه فكانت
اكثر مباشره في اتخاذ موقف واضح لا من مال
الانتخابات بل من شخص الرئيس اردوغان مع
صوره ارفقتها بعنوان هل سنتخلص منه اخيرا
في مقاله في ميدل ايست اي يقول ديفيد هيرت
ان زجاجات الشمبانيا ستفتح احتفالا من
برلين الى واشنطن ان خسر اردوغان
الانتخابات زخم من العناوين والتغطيه من
ساحات اعلاميه دوليه عديده تكاد تتقاسم
نفس المعاني واحيانا العبارات تناول يطرح
سؤالا عن طبيعه علاقه وسائل اعلام غربيه
بالحدث التركي وكيف تقدمه لجمهورها بتتبع
ما تكتبه الصحف الغربيه فانها تفرد مساحه
من مقالاتها لموقف تركيا من الحرب في
اوكرانيا وكيف انها تحافظ على موقف يوازن
بين عضويتها في النيتو وعلاقاتها
الاستثنائيه بكل من موسكو تقول بلومبرج ان
لدى الغرب املا ان يؤدي تغيير القياده في
انقره الى عوده تركيا السريعه الى منظومه
النيتو بعد سنوات م ما تعتبره انحرافا الى
الشرق في الوقت الذي يواجه فيه الحلف اكبر
تحد له ممثلا في الحرب في اوكرانيا
فالناتو سيكون سعيدا بجعل تركيا جزءا من
الاجماع بدلا من كونها مربكا له
ينضم الينا من اسطنبول لاستاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه ايدين الدكتور طالق
اوبزولو دكتور طارق لنبدا بالحديث عن
الحملات الانتخابيه والمهرجانات داخل
تركيا في هذه الدوره الانتخابيه بماذا
تختلف هذه الحملات الانتخابيه عما سبقها
في الدورات الماضيه
اعتقد ان هذا سؤال مهم هذه الانتخابات
البرلمانيه والرئاسيه التي ستجري في احد
القادم مهمه جدا لمستقبلي البلاد وفي هذه
الحمله الانتخابيه راينا ان هنالك
مجموعتان
تحالف الشعب الذي يحتوي سته احزاب مختلفه
يحارب ضد ويقف ضد التحالف
الحكوميه وايضا حكم ايضا حزب العداله
والديمقراطيه مع حزب الافعال بالتالي فان
هذين التحالف فانهم لا يقامون بجمع
يقومون بجمع الاجناس من
مجالات حياتيه مختلفه هنالك تجمع شعبي
كبير لكن راينا ان
تحالف
الشعبي والحزب الحاكم هو يؤكد على اهميه
الامن
والدفاع والرئيس اردوغان
اشاره الى نجاحاته في الماضي لكن من الجهه
الاخرى فانها حزب فان تحالف الشعبي هو
ينتقد الحكومه لسياساتها والاعتماد على
نقاط محدده اولها انه كان هنالك ازمه
اقتصاديه مررنا بها وقد خبرنا ايضا
الهزه الارضيه والزلزال خلال الاشهر
الماضيه وقد كان هنالك عدم رضا شعبي رتجه
السياسات الحكوميه لكن من الجهه الاخر
نعرف ان هنالك جزء كبير من المجتمع يدعم
التحالف الحاكم ومن الصعب جدا القول اي من
هذا التح الفين سيخرج منتصرا من هذه في
هذه الانتخابات القضاء
هو مستقل ويراقب اعتقد ان
ما هو مهم ايضا ان هنالك عدد كبير من
الشعب التركيه يستمر بالدعم التحالف
الحاكم برغم حقيقه انه
مررنا باوقات صعبه وخاصه بالنسبه للوضع
الاقتصادي للبلاد هذا الامر يظهر ان
الرئيس اردوغان قد نجح في تاسيس نوعا من
الكيمياء الخاصه مع الراي العام وهذا امر
مهم
طيب يعني رغم ذلك عفوا يعني رغم كل ما
قدمته الان
لاحظنا ان هناك تركيز غربي يعني عدا عن
الداخل التركي هناك تركيز غربي خارجي على
هذه الانتخابات واهتمام كبير ربما لا سابق
له لكن من زاويه
دعم المعارضه من زاويه تشويه صوره الرئيس
اردوغان لماذا برايك نحت وسائل الاعلام
الغربيه او معظم وسائل الاعلام الغربيه
الاساسيه بهذا الاتجاه قبل الانتخابات
نعم نعم انا اوافقك الراي ان
وسائل الاعلام الغربيه والصحف الغربيه
قد اوضحت انها تدعم المعارضه وحل فيها
لانها غير راضيه بالسياسات الخارجيه
للتحالف الحكم وهم يعرفون ان الرئيس
اردوغان
ليس يتمتع بعلاقات طيبه مع
اطراف الغربيه هو ايضا وضع
سياسته واستراتيجيته الاقتصاديه في جوهر
السياسه الخارجيه وايضا يعرفون ان تركيا
تتمتع بعلاقات جيده مع روسيا وايضا لم تقض
مواقف ضد روسيا في النيتو لكن علينا ان لا
ننسى حقيقه ان وسائل الاعلام الغربيه في
السابق دعمت التحالف الحاكم هي دعمت
الرئيس اردوغان بالتالي الرئيس اردوغان
قام بدعم الاجراءات
لتحديث واضافه الطابع الغربيه في البلاد
كان
اعتقد اليوم انهم يدعمون المعارضه لانهم
يعتقدون انهم اذا ما تسلمت المعارضه
السلطه فان تركيا ستستمر بتحسين علاقاتها
مع الاتحاد الاوروبي والنيترون تركيا ايضا
تجعلوا من الممكن ان يكون هنالك علاقات
افضل مع الغرب شكرا لك دكتور طارق اجوزلو
كنت معنا من اسطنبول استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه ايدي
مشاهدينا انها راس الساعه منتصف الليل
مستمرون معكم في جوله الحصاد وهذا تفكير
بالعناوين
مع استمرار المعارك حول مواقع استراتيجيه
في الخرطوم مفاوضات في جده لليوم الثاني
بحضور ممثلين عن الجيش والدعم السريع رئيس
وفد الجيش يقول للجزيره ان التفاوض يدور
حول هدنه انسانيه قصيره لفتح ممرات امنه
من تحول الصراع في السودان الى حرب اهليه
تصيد ميداني في اوكرانيا كياف تقول ان
القوات الروسيه كثفت حده القصف على بخموت
باستخدام اسلحه ثقيله ومتطوره
فاجنر الروسيه تعلن بقائها في جبهات بخمود
بعد وعد بامدادات روسيا تعلن انها صده
هجوما جديدا بمسيارات في شبه جزيره القرم
وجروسي يحذر من حدث نووي خطير محتمل مع
اخلاء منطقه قريبه من محطه
سباق مع الزمن واتصالات مكثفه بواشنطن
وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه تحذر مما اسمته
فوضى ماليه واقتصاديه وكارثه للنظام
المالي العالمي حال الاخفاق في ابرام
تسويه بشان رفع سقف الذيل العام قبل الاول
من يونيو
والجمهوريون يحملون بيض المسؤوليه الازمه
برفضه التفاوض حول اولويات الانفاق
ومستوياته
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل الجزيره في الخرطوم بسماع
اصوات اطلاق نار في المدينه كما افاد
مراسل الجزيره بتجدد الاشتباكات بالاسلحه
الثقيله والخفيفه بين الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع وسط الخرطوم في الاثناء
حلقه طائرات حربيه في سماء الخرطوم
والخرطوم بحري كما سمعت اصوات اسلحه ثقيله
وخفيفه متقطعه في محيط القصر الرئاسي ووسط
الخرطوم
ينضم الينا من جنوب الخرطوم مراسله
الجزيره محمد الطيب محمد كيف يبدو الوضع
منتصف الليل في جنوب الخرطوم تحديدا هي
المنطقه يعني التي شهدت مؤخرا ربما فترات
هدوء اكثر من من وسط الخرطوم
عموما قبل نحو ساعتين ساده الهدوء الحذر
المناطق جنوب الخرطوم وجنوب شرق الخرطوم
في الواقع لم نسمع بشكل من الاشكال
الاشتباكات الواضحه كما كنا نسمعها في
فتره ما بعد صلاه العشاء وبعد المغرب
تماما كانت هناك اشتباكات واصوات لمدفعيه
في وسط الخرطوم كنا نسمعها هنا واضحه من
جنوب الخرطوم الان بالنسبه للمواطنين في
هذه المناطق ينظرون ويتابعون باهتمام
ستخرج عنه المفاوضات في مدينه جده
السعوديه
ويتبنون ان تفضي هذه المفاوضات الى حل
والى شك من اشكال الاستمرار والى هدنه
حقيقيه يستطيعون من خلالها تغطيه
احتياجاتهم الصحيه والماليه وغيرها من
الاحتياجات العامه عموما جغرافيه العمليات
والمواجهات خلال الفتره الماضيه لم تتغير
كثيره كانت معظمها تدور في المناطق القصر
الرئاسي المحيطه بالقصر الر والقياده
العامه ومطار الخرطوم بالاضافه الى منطقه
الجريف شرق شرق النيل عموما والمناطق
الجنوبيه لمنطقه بحري وهنا نتحدث عن منطقه
الصبابي ومنطقه حله حماه هذه المناطقيه
متاخمه وشاطئه في الجانب الاخر للقصر
الجمهوري جغرافي لم تتغير كثيرا خلال
ثلاثه ايام الماضيه هناك مناوشات تحصل بين
الفينه والاخرى واشتباكات ما بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع لكن
باعتقادنا ان هذا اليوم ايضا كان هناك قصف
في مناطق وسط الخرطوم وفي المقر
الوزاريه التي حولها القصر الجمهوري كنا
نسمعها بوضوح ودوي انفجارات هنا بوضوح من
هذه المنطقه عموما لكن المناطق الجنوبيه
الشرقيه من العاصمه الخرطوم الساده فيها
هدولا يكن هناك اشتباكات واضحه نسمع الى
اخر انما يعلق الطيران الدعم السريع تقوم
بارسال مضاداتها واطلاق مضادات الابعاد
الطائرات من المناطق التي هم ايتها
يتواجدون فيها بشكل او باخر في الجغرافيا
لم تتغير كثيرا ولكن هناك اهتمام شعبي
واهتمام بالنسبه للمواطنين ان تفضي هذه
المفاوضات التي انطلقت في جده الى حل يخفف
عنهم
الحاله الفزع والخوف الذي
ما زالت يعني تخيم عليهم خلال الاسبوعين
الثلاثه اسابيع الماضيه شكرا الان في
الاسبوع الرابع كما تعلم
محمد الطيب مراسل الجزيره من جنوب الخرطوم
سياسيا اكد طرفان نزاع في السودان
مشاركتهما في محادثات تعقد في مدينه جده
السعوديه هي الاولى منذ اندلاع الازمه وقد
رحبت الرياض وواشنطن بالمحادثات الاوليه
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريه
واعربت اعمالهما في ان تؤدي الى انهاء
النزاع وقال المتحدث باسم الجيش السوداني
العميد نبيل عبد الله ان تفوض يبحث اليات
تمديد الهدنه ولا يشمل اي اتفاق نهائي
لوقت اطلاق النار او قضايا سياسيه
ودع وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري طرفي
الازمه في السودان الى العوده للحوار
السياسي وقال في اجتماع لمجلس الجامعه
العربيه على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه العرب
انه يتعين وقت اطلاق النار في السودان
وضمان الالتزام به
بدورها اكدت الهيئه الحكوميه الدوليه
للتنميه ايجاد انها تتابع عن كسب محادثات
وقت اطلاق النار بين ممثلي الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع التي بدات في جده وحثت
الجانبين على اغتنام فرصه المحادثات وجها
لوجه لاسكات البنادق ودعت منظمه ايجاد
الطرفين الى الموافقه الفوريه وغير
المشروطه على وقف اطلاق النار لاسباب
انسانيه مشيره الى ان ذلك من شانه السماح
للسكان المدنيين والعائلات بالوصول الى
الحمايه والممرات الامنه للتنقل وخدمات
الرعايه الصحيه وتلبيه احتياجاتهم
الغذائيه وكانت منظمه ايجاد قد بدات
مبادره للوساطه بين طرفي النزاع بارسالها
بعثه سلام رفيعه المستوى تضم رؤساء جنوب
السودان وكينيا وجيبوتي الى الخرطوم لحث
الطرفين على وقف اطلاق النار
حذر الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيريش من تحول الصراع في السودان الى
حرب اهليه وقال غوتيرش اثناء زيارته لدوله
الكونغو الديمقراطيه انه يجب ان يتوقف
القتال على الفور قبل ان يتحول هذا الصراع
الى حرب اهليه يمكن ان تدمر البلاد وتعطل
المنطقه لسنوات قادمه مشددا على ضروره عمل
جميع الاطراف على نزع فتيل التوترات
والجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات والاتفاق على
وقف اطلاق نار مستقر ودائم
اعين الجميع نحو جده السعوديه تزامنا مع
تواصل عمليات الاجلاء عبر مينائها يجري
طرف الصراع في السودان محادثات لاول مره
ترحب الرياض واشنطن وتعربان عن الامل في
الوصول لنهايه النزاع يحدد الجيش السوداني
شكل هذه المحادثات يقول ان الجلسات تبحث
فقط اليات تمديد الهدنه ولا تشمل اي اتفاق
نهائي لوقف اطلاق النار او قضايا سياسيه
اعين الاتحاد الافريقي على جده كذلك يقدم
الاتحاد الازمه الانسانيه امام الطرفين
داعيا لوقف القتال على وجه السرعه يتحرك
الامين العام للامم المتحده يصل الى
العاصمه الاثيوبيه ويلتقي رئيس الوزراء
ورئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي يكشف مصدر
للجزيره ان الامم المتحده والاتحاد
الافريقي سيقدمان خارطه طريق لانهاء
الازمه يعرب غوتيريش من اديس ابابا عن
قلقه من تداعيات في السودان على المنطقه
وخاصه دول الجوار يصف بوتيرج هذه الدول
بالهشه وتلك الدول تستقبل وتصدر اللاجئين
بالملايين بسبب ازماتها الداخليه امنيا
وغدائيا اذ يستقبل السودان اكثر من مليون
لاجئ هربوا اليه من دول الجوار اثيوبيا
وجنوب السودان تحديدا اصبح السودان الان
يصدر اللاجئين الى هذه الدول ما يزيد من
الازمه الانسانيه في المنطقه ككل تتاثر
مصر فيتحرك وزير خارجيتها في جوله اقليميه
كذلك ولكن بعد ثلاثه اسابيع يتوجه سامح
شكري الى تشاد وجنوب السودان يبحث فيهما
عن حل للازمه هو الاخر استقبلت مصر عشرات
الالاف من اللاجئين السودانيين خلال
الاسابيع القليله الماضيه المسؤولون
المصريون قلقون على اقتصادهم المعتمد بشكل
كبير على السودان في لمحه سريعه على الامر
يش تبادل التجاريه بين مصر والسودان اكثر
من 13% من التبادل التجاري المصري مع
افريقيا مجتمعه رقم كبير يعكس الاعتماد
المصريه على جواره الجنوبي لا سيما في
الامن الغذائي اما الامن بمفهوم التقليدي
فيؤرق القاهره وهي تراقب حدودا تتجاوز الف
ومئتين كم قد تفتح على مصرعيها اذا انهار
النظام الامي في السودان بسبب القتال
التحركات الاخيره تاتي بعد تحركات اقليميه
اخرى لم تفضي الى نتائج عمليه طرحت منظمه
الايجاد الافريقيه مبادره للحل وقررت
افاده رؤساء كينيا وجنوب السودان وجيبوتي
بحثا عن ذلك الحل التزمنا ذلك مع استعداد
من جنوب السودان لاستضافه طرفي السرعه لكن
كل ذلك مره دون اثر لذلك يترقب الجميع
محادثات جده السودانيون ليسوا وحدهم من
ينتظر نهايه هذه الازمه
[موسيقى]
تنضموا الينا من عاصمه هاري من هراري
عاصمه زيمبابوي سفيره الاتحاد الافريقي
السابقه لدى واشنطن الدكتوره ابي كان شي
هومبوري دكتوره اريكانه ما الذي يتوقعها
الاتحاد الافريقي من
محادثات جده
هنالك كانت تقطع في الصوت سالتك عن ما
الذي يمكن ان يتوقعه برايك الاتحاد
الافريقي من محادثات جده وهو الذي كان
منخرطا اساسا في
جهود حل الازمه في السودان
بالتاكيد القضيه في السودان هي قضيه تخص
الاتحاد الافريقي والاتحاد الافريقي هو
يقود الحديث هناك نعم نحن نقدر
الولايات المتحده والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه لدعوتهم لعقد هذا الاجتماع
اعتقدوا ان من المهم ان يفهم الجميع ان
الوضع في السودان هو وضع
له متعدد الاطراف نحن نعم نتعامل مع
القضايا المتعلقه بالجنرانين اللذان
يتنافسان على السلطه وعلينا ان نتعامل مع
المسببات التي ادت الى السودان الى ان
ينتهي الى الوضع الذي موجود هو هناك هذه
القوات الخارجيه المسؤوله عن عدم
الاستقرار في السودان عليها ايضا ان يتم
التعامل معها ويتم التعامل معها بشكل حاسم
لا يمكننا ان نتعامل مع القضايا الجانبيه
ونركز على الجنرالين فقط لكن هنالك عناصر
اخرى
يجب قضايا اخرى يجب ان نتعامل معها انا
امل ان الولايات المتحده والسعوديه
وبالتعامل مع الاتحاد الافريقي
يتمكنون من التحدث عن اللاعبين او الاطراف
الجيو السياسيه الاخرى
يعني لاغني ما الذي تقصدينه عفوا سيده
اريكانا لا ادري ما الذي تقصدون تقصدينه
وكانك يعني تقولين بان محادثات جدا غير
كافيه
وان هناك عناصر اخرى يجب ان تؤخذ
بالاعتبار كما انه يجب ان يكون الاتحاد
الافريقي طرفا في هذه المحادثات
انا اقول ان الاتحاد الافريقي يجب ان يكون
دائما وان يكون دائما قائدا لهذه
المحادثات لان هذه مشكله تخص افريقيا ونحن
في لحظه نقول فيها ان الحلول الافريقيه
يجب ان تكون هذه المشاكل الافريقيه لكن
علينا ان نتعامل مع المشكله برمتها لا
يمكنها ان نتحدث فقط عن الجنرال
برهاني نعم هم ايه تسارعان عن السلطه وهذا
صراع السلطه يجب ان لا يستمر لكن علينا ان
نقرا الافريقي يعني حتى الان يبدو انه لم
يتمكن حتى عفوا سيده اريكانا باختصار
الاتحاد الافريقي يبدو انه حتى لم يتمكن
من دفع الطرفين الى القبول بمحادثات من
اجل هدنه يعني فشل حتى في في الوساطه على
هذا الطريق
صوتك يتقطع لكنني اعمل انني فهمت سؤالك
الاتحاد الافريقي يبدو المابي جهد ما
بوسعه من اجل التعامل مع القضايا والمشاكل
في افريقيا لكن ما هو في جوهري هذه
القضايا هنالك قوى خارجيه مسؤوله لهذه
لبدء هذا الصراع بالتالي نحن نتعامل مع
يجب علينا ان نتعامل مع اسس هذه المشكله
ما الذي سبب السودان ان يكون في هذا
الموقف وان علينا نعم ان نتعامل مع
جنرالات وعن نتعامل مع القوى الخارجيه
والاطراف الخارجيه التي تقع عليها مسؤوليه
هذا ان الصراع مستمره في السودان استمر
لان هنالك مصالح خارجيه ان التعامل مع
الجنرالين فقط لن يحل هذه المشكله
الموجوده الان في السودان من هراريه عاصمه
زيمبابوي سفيره الاتحاد الافريقي السابقه
لدى واشنطن الدكتوره اريكان
بوري
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت
بل اعلنت في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كياف حاله
التاهب الجويه وافاد مراسل الجزيره ان
حاله تاهب شملت كذلك مقاطعات شمال وجنوب
اوكرانيا كما دوله انفجارات في مدن اوديسا
وزبولوجيا
للمزيد من التفاصيل ينضم الينا من
ميكولايف مراسلة جزيره تامر الصمادي ومن
كياد مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود والبدايه
معك حسان وحاله التاهب الجوي التي
اعلنت في العاصمه ومناطق في الشمال
والجنوب
نعم حسن هذه الحاله اعلنت قبل حوالي
الساعه من الان في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كما
في عدد من المقاطعات الشماليه
والجنوبيه قبل دقائق من الان اكدت الاداره
العسكريه في كييف ان الدفاعات الجويه في
هذه الاثناء تتعامل مع اهداف جويه وتحاول
تحيد خطر جوي على الاغلب ووفق معلومات
اوليه هي مسيرات تطير في اجواء ضواحي
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كما ان عدد من السكان
ايضا رصدوا وجود اجسام طائره في سماء كل
من منطقتي جيتومر في المنطقه الغربيه غرب
كييف بالاضافه ايضا الى منطقه تشيرني هاف
شمال اوكرانيا هذه المناطق تشهد حركه في
الاجواء حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم الاعلان
بشكل واضح
رسمي عن طبيعه هذه الاجسام الطائره التي
تتجه نحو تلك المناطق الا ان المعلومات
الاوليه المؤكده ان الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه تعمل في هذه الاثناء في محاوله
للتصدي لهذه الهجمات الجويه التي لم تختصر
فقط على هذه المناطق في وسط وشمال
اوكرانيا انما ايضا تمتد الى المنطقه
الجنوبيه وهناك الزميل تامر الصمادي ايضا
لديه المزيد من التفاصيل
تامر بالفعل يعني ذوي انفجارات ايضا في
العديد من المدن الجنوبيه كيف يبدو المشهد
هذا المساء
بالفعل حسن لليوم الثاني على التوالي في
مثل هذا التوقيت يتجدد القصف الانفجارات
في مقاطعات جنوبيه عده بالتزامن في هذه
الاثناء وانا اتحدث اليك
تتجدد الانفجارات في خير سون في اوديسا
فيزا في دينيبرو والحديث عن نوعين من
الانفجارات انفجارات
بالانفجارات مردها الى صواريخ تنطلق من
البحر الاسود وفقا للادارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه وانفجارات اخرى كما قال زميل
حسان مسعود في كييف ناتجه عن مسيرات
طائرات من دون طيار تنطلق من اكثر في اكثر
من اتجاه في المقاطعات الجنوبيه الحديث
وفقا
لعمده عن طائرات من نوع شاهد ايرانيه
الصنع وفي هذه الاثناء ايضا تتحدث قياده
عمليات
الاوكرانيه عن حاله من الخطر المتصاعد
الناتج عن البحر الاسود الحديث عن ارتفاع
وفقا للسلطات العسكريه الاوكرانيه ارتفاع
عدد
القطاعات او القطع البحريه الخاصه بالقوات
الروسيه في البحر الاسود الى اكثر من عشره
الحديد صباح هذا اليوم كان يتمحور حول سته
من السفن العسكريه الان الحديث عن اكثر من
عشره بالاضافه الى اربعه من حاملات
الصواريخ الحديث عن صواريخ مجنحه من نوع
كليبر الحديث ايضا عن تحليق طائرات
استراتيجيه تصفها السلطات الاوكرانيه من
بحر قزوين وهذه الطائرات قد تكون محمله
بصواريخ مجنحه الحديث ايضا عن حاله التاهب
الجويه التي تطال كل الجنوب الاوكراني قبل
قليل فقط يعني دوره صافرات الانذار هنا في
ميكولايف وميكولايف كانت تعرضت الليله
الماضيه وفجر امس
لانفجارات متتاليه في قلب المدينه اليوم
الانفجارات تمحورت في المناطق الريفيه
والمناطق الساحليه من ميكولايف ونهايه حتى
هذه اللحظه السلطات هناك تتحدث عن
انفجارات متتاليه في قلب المدينه وعلى طول
القران الواقعه على خط التماس بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه نعم
شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا لحسن مسعود كان معنا
من كييف
ونتابع في شان الاوكراني ينضموا الينا من
كيافه ايضا الدكتور ايضا اوس كبير
الباحثين في المعاهد الاوكرانيه للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه ومن موسكو
الباحث في المجلس الروسي لشؤون الدوليه
معك سيد اليكسي سابدا بالحديث من حيث
انتهى زميل تامر الصمادي من منطقه الجنوب
تلك المنطقه التي يعني
تشهد سخونه كبيره في الاونه الاخيره وايضا
تشهد جماد على شبه جزيره القرم اضافه الى
اخلاء مدنيين من خيرسون من زابولوجيا ومن
مناطق اخرى ما الذي تتوقعه موسكو لهذه
الجبهه في الايام القادمه
هناك
استنتاجات من المرحله الاولى من العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه وهذا ما نسمي هذه العمليه
الروسيا تستعد لتصادم قوي مع القوات
الاوكرانيه بما فيها الفرق التي حضرت من
قبل الدول الغربيه في اوكرانيا وفي حسب
القواعد العسكريه والدفاعيه روسيا مستعده
لما نسميه الهجمات العسكريه العكسيه
الاوكرانيه التي تجهز ولا ارى اي شيء
مخيفه او غير عادي في هذا لدينا قلاع
للدفاع والمدنيين يتم اجلائهم للاماكن
الامنه والقوات العسكريه الروسيه تحضر ضد
هذه الهجمات العكسيه الاوكرانيه
ربما نفس السؤال ساساله الى ضيفي من كييف
عما تحضر له له اوكرانيا
وهل فعلا الهجوم المضاد سيبدا من من
الجنوب كما يروج
مساء الخير من كييف
ارحب بكم وارحب الضيف من موسكو وارحب
المشاهدين وتعلمون ان المكان الذي سوف
تبدا منه الهجمات العكسيه هو سر لا يعرفه
احد هناك بعض التوقعات ربما الجنوب او
ربما او قطاع ذابولوجيا او ربما قطاع
لوغانس ولذلك هناك ثلاث خيارات على الاقل
كبدايه لهذه العمليات وهناك احتمال ان
يكون البدء من بخ موت حيث يظهر
بجوجل انه سوف يدافع عن تلك المنطقه
ولكننا نفهم ان لدى روسيا ان روسيا ليست
مستعده للدفاع هناك بالرغم من انهم في
موقف الهجوم
ونعتقد انه لن يكون هناك الكثير من
الاشكال الاسلحه لدى روسيا في تلك المواقع
ولذلك من الصعبه ان نتحدث عن متى سوف تبدا
هذه الهجمات فريجوجل تحدث عن ان هذا قد
يكون قبل الخامس عشر من مايو ولكن دعونا
ننتظر قد يكون بريجوجل يعلم خطط اوكرانيا
افضل من اي شخص اخر في اوكرانيا شكرا
يعني
يعلم اكثر من اي شخص اخر في في اوكرانيا
طبعا انت يعني تتحدث عن ذلك
بسخريه ولكن يعني
اليوم هو قد يكون
سيد الموقف في منطقه
وهذا ما ساساله للسيد اليكسي يعني
لماذا لماذا يبدو
وشركه فاجنر اكثر قدره على التحرك اكثر
قدره على التقدم في باخموت يقوم بما يعجز
الجيش الروسي عن القيام به الى درجه انه
يصبح موضع حسد
[موسيقى]
وموضع تزاحم من قبل وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان روسيا في هذا النزاع تستخدم
بعض اشكال
العمليات العسكريه وهذا ما تتميز به
فاجنر عن القوات النظاميه ان روسيا لديها
جيش ضخم وهي ليست سهله في التحرك بينما
شركه فاجنر هي مجموعات صغيره سهله التحرك
ولديها تواصل مباشر بين القياده والجنود
وحيث تتخذ القرارات
بشكل مباشر من القيادات وليس من الهيئه
العسكريه العليا الموجوده في موسكو وهذه
الوسيله في هذه الحرب وخاصه في المواقع في
المدن في سليد دار حيث
سيطرت
فاقنر فرضت السيطره منذ اشهر وهذا نجح
ايضا في بخمت
لا ارى في هذا اي مشكله حقيقه بالنسبه
للقوات الروسيه بل ارى في هذا وسيله
عقلانيه علميه فان النجاح هو اقرب لمن
يستطيع ان يتاقلم مع الظروف ولكن يعني على
الرغم من ذلك هو ينتقد وينتقد بشده عدم
وصول الاسلحه اليه ويصل الى اتهام
المسؤولين الروس بالخيانه في بعض الاحيان
هنا سانتقل الى السيد اليكسي من كييف من
جديد هذا الهجوم المضاد الذي تتوعد به
اوكرانيا
ماذا لو لم يكن على قدر التوقعات الغربيه
تحديدا والامريكيه بشكل خاص
كل شيء ممكن ان يكون لن
ابعد هذا
الخيار ولكننا نحضر حتى تكون فعاله وناجحه
من الممكن كان من الممكن ان نبدا من قبل
في شهر ابريل ولكننا نفهم اننا حتى تكون
هذه الهجمات ناجحه وحتى تاتي بثمار
المنتظره يجب ان نقوم بالتحضير في ظروف
افضل لنا والمعدات الحديثه التي تتدرب
عليها الجنود تحتاج
ان تكون التربه جافه والان في اوكرانيا
انتهت موسم الامطار
وسوف تكون استخدام هذه المعدات اكثر
فعاليه
ونجحنا في التدريب عليه في الايام
السابقه على سبيل المثال انظمه الدفاع
الجويه الحديثه ومنذ يومين كما تعلمون
اسقطنا صاروخ كنجار الفرد صوتيه التي كانت
تعتبر مستحيله للرادارات والانظمه الدفاع
الجويه وهذه لاول مره في التاريخ ان تدمر
هذه الصواريخ بانظمه باتريوت وهذا يثبت ان
هذه الاسلحه ندرب عليها بشكل جيد
وعندما
يقرر الجنرالات وفي الهيئه العسكريه
العليا متى سنبدا واين عندها سوف تكون
اكثر فعاليه ولا يعلم احد
ولا احد يعلم اين سيكون هذا وقد يكون في
بحر الازوت
وحدوده اذن دكتور ايضا اوس من كييف كبيره
الباحثين في المعهد الاوكراني للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه اشكرك جزيلا وشكرا
لالكسنوموف الباحث في المجلس الروسي
للشؤون الدوليه كان معنا من موسكو
[موسيقى]
عشيه محادثات حاسمه بين الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن وزعماء الجمهوريين بشان رفع سقف
الدين العام قالت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه
جاني ان عدم رفع سقف الدين العام سيتسبب
في عدم قدره الولايات المتحده على تسديد
ديونها واضافت في لقاء مع محطه التلفزيون
اي بي سي ان فشل الكونجرس في رفع سقف
الدين الامريكي بحلول الاول من يونيو
سيحدث عواقب اقتصاديه في السوق الماليه
اذا لم يرفع سقف الدين فستجد وزاره
الخزانه نفسها في وضع لا يمكن فيه دفع
مستحقاتنا في الاول من يونيو وستكون هذه
المره الاولى في تاريخ الولايات المتحده
التي نفشل فيها في سداد المدفوعات
المستحقه وهذا سيتسبب بفوضى ماليه
واقتصاديه حيث ان سندات الخزانه الامريكيه
هي الاكثر امانا في النظام المالي العالمي
واخفاق الولايات المتحده في سداد ديونها
من شانه ان يثير التساؤل عن اهليتنا
الائتمانيه من المحتمل ان نرى عواقب
اقتصاديه في السوق الماليه اذا لم يتحرك
الكونجرس سريعا
ومع استمرار تماسك رئيس الكونجرس الجمهوري
كيدن بخفض الميزانيه قبل الوصول الى اتفاق
قال رئيس لجنه الخدمه الماليه بمجلس
النواب الامريكي الجمهوري باتريك ماشينري
ان قرار رفعي صفي الدين العام يتعلق بمجلس
الشيوخ ذي الاغلبيه الديمقراطيه وليس
النواب ذي الاغلبيه الجمهوريه واضاف
ماشينري في لقاء مع محطه سي بي اس
الاخباريه الامريكيه ان الرئيس جو بايدن
بحاجه الى حل توافقي ينهي ازمه الدين
العام في الولايات المتحده
تعاملنا في مجلس النواب مع ملفات النمو
والانفاق الفوري والمدخرات طويله الاجل
بشكل متوازن ضمن خطتنا ورفعناه الى مجلس
الشيوخ الرئيس قال لنا ارونا خطتكم لقد
فعلنا لم نكشف خطتنا فقط بل مررناها ايضا
بمجلس النواب لكن مجلس الشيوخ لم يمررها
لان هناك ثلاثه واربعين عضوا يقولون انهم
لا يوافق على خطه الشمر الان يتعين على
الرئيس ان ياتي الى الطاوله للتوصل الى حل
تفاوضى عليه ان يستمع لمستشاره
الاقتصاديين لاسياسيين
وفي التطور الاحداث للسجال بشان ازمه سقف
الدين العام قال البيت الابيض ان طلب
الجمهوريين تقليصا مليارات من تمويل
الاعمال التجاريه الحيويه قد يعرقل سداد
الدين الامريكي
على شفا ازمه ماليه غير مسبوقه تجد
الولايات المتحده نفسها بعد تاكيد وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه جانتيلين استنفاذ كل
التدابير الاستثنائيه خلال الاشهر القليله
الماضيه لتلاف تبعات وصول البلاد الى حد
الدين القانوني البالغي واحدا وثلاثين
تريليونا و400 مليار دولار وفشل الكونغرس
حتى الان في التوصل لاتفاق بشان رفع سقف
الدين ما يعني عجز الولايات المتحده لاول
مره في التاريخ عن الوفاء بالتزاماتها
الماليه والتخلف عن سداد ديونها وقد يتسبب
ذلك في ضرر لا يمكن اصلاحه للاقتصاد
الامريكي وسبل عيش جميع الامريكيين
والاستقرار المالي العالمي كما سبق وحذرت
وزيره الخزانه قبل عده اسابيع لكن كيف وصل
الحال في الولايات المتحده الى هذا
السيناريو الكارثي رغم نذره منذ مطلع
العام الحالي القصه بدات عندما قرر
الكونجرس الامريكي عام
1917 وضع اجراء تم بموجبه تحديد السقف
الاقصى الذي يمكن للحكومه استدانته وذلك
لتغطيه العجز بين ايراداتها ونفقاتها لكي
تتمكن من تامين الاموال اللازمه لرواتب
الموظفين والعسكريين وشكات الضمان
الاجتماعي وخدمات الرعايه الصحيه وغيرها
من اوجه النفقات الحكوميه ويتم ذلك اي
اقتراض الحكومه للاموال عبر طرح السندات
الحكوميه التي ينظر لها عالميا على انها
استثمار امن وموثوق وتحتاج الحكومه في حال
الوصول الى سقف الدين العام الى موافقه
الكونجرس اي مجلسي النواب والشيوخ لرفعه
مجددا وحتى اليوم يرفض الجمهوريون الذين
يسيطرون على مجلس النواب الموافقه على هذه
الخطوه ويشترطون اجراء تخفيضات في
الميزانيه الحكوميه الامر الذي ترفضه
اداره بايدن وتتهم خصومها في الكونجرس
باخذ الاقتصاد الامريكي رهينه في ايديهم
لدفعها للقيام باقتطاعات جائره من
الميزانيه وفي حال عجز الطرفين عن التوصل
للاتفاق قبل يونيو القادم فان اسواق المال
الامريكيه والعالميه مهدده بالتعرض لخسائر
فادحه فضلا عن فقدان النظام المالي
الامريكي لموثوقيته الدوليه واستوقعات بان
يدخل الاقتصاد الامريكي فخر كود وان يفقد
سوق العمل الامريكي اكثر من سته ملايين
فرصه عمل ما يعني ارتفاع معدلات البطاله
بشكل قياسي
[موسيقى]
الان الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه حيث اقتحمت
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه بلده اليامون
غرب جنين وحصلت منزلا في البلده واندلعت
اشتباكات مع مقومين فلسطينيين ما اجبر
جنود الاحتلال على الانسحاب من المكان
واشنت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الليله
الماضيه وفجر اليوم حمله دام وتفتيش في
مناطق مختلفه بالضفه الغربيه تخللتها
مواجهات في منطقتين نابلس وجنين
في ظل الارتفاع وتيره اقتحامات القوات
الاسرائيليه للمدن الفلسطينيه تبث الجزيره
مساء الاثنين حلقه خاصه من برنامج للقصه
بقيه الذي تقدمها الزميل فيروز زياني
تتضمن تحقيقا يكشف الاستراتيجيات العسكريه
والاستخباراتيه التي تتبعها وحده مستعربين
خلال اقتحاماتها في الضفه الغربيه ويوثق
البرنامج شهاده حصريه لاحد العناصر
السابقين في وحده المستعربين عن تفاصيل
عمل الوحده ودورها في الاقتحانات كما يكشف
التحقيق بالمحاكاه الهندسيه اليات
الاقتحام والمراحل التي تمر بها ويوافق
استخدام الاطفال الفلسطينيين كدروع بشريه
خلال اقتحامات القوات الخاصه الاسرائيليه
برنامج للقصه بقيه الذي تقدمها زميل فيروز
زياني يعرض الاثنين في العاشره وخمس دقائق
مساء بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
قرر برنامج الاغذيه العالميه تعليق
مساعداته لالاف الاسر الفلسطينيه اعتبارا
من الشهر المقبل بسبب نقص حاد في التمويل
وقال البرنامج التابع للامم المتحده في
بيان انه اضطر الى اتخاذ خيارات مؤلمه
للتعامل مع محدوديه الموارد المتاحه حاليا
وذلك لضمان استمرار المساعدات الغذائيه
الحيويه للاسر الاشد احتياجا وهي مسح
القرار اكثر من 200 الف فلسطيني اي 60 في
المئه من المستفيدين من مساعدات البرنامج
في كل من الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه الذي
يشهد على معدلات انعدام الامن الغذائي
والفقر في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
وينبه برنامج الاغذيه العالميه لانه ما لم
يتلقى تمويلا فسوف يضطر الى تعليق
المساعدات الغذائيه والنقديه للفلسطينيين
بالكامل بحلول شهر اغسطس اب المقبل
ينضموا الينا من غزه امجد شور رئيس شبكه
المنظمات الاليه في قطاع غزه مرحبا بك سيد
امجد اولا ما الاثر المباشر لهذا القرار
تعليق برنامج الاغذيه العالمي مساعداته
واقتصارها الان
ومؤقتا ايضا للاسر الاشد احتياجا كما يقول
شكرا جزيلا على تسليط الضوء على هذا
الموضوع البالغ الاهميه اولا نحن امام
ازمه سياسيه مرتبطه
بانتهاكات منظمه ارتكبها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي حقوق الانسان من خلال فرض
الحصار واستمرار على كافه المستويات
وتداعياته الخطيره ومقدمه ذلك الواقع
الاقتصادي الاجتماعي الانساني عندما نتحدث
عن الارقام والنسب اكثر من 60% من سكان
قطاع غزه هم من الفقراء
ايضا نسبه الفقر حسب
الاحصائيات الاخيره تقريبا 46% من السكان
وخاصه ان هناك 73% نسبه البطاله بين صفوف
الشباب انعدام الامن الغذائي اكثر من 65%
من سكان قطاع غزه يعانون منعدام الامن
الغذائي برنامج الغذاء العالمي هو احد
البرامج المهمه التي تقدم المساعدات
الغذائيه للاسر الاكثر تهميشا واكثر حاجه
في المجتمع الفلسطيني وبخاصه في قطاع غزه
هناك كان
البرنامج يقدم لمساعدات الاكثر من 420
الفهم لنفهم كيف يعمل هذا البرنامج لنفهم
هذا البرنامج
يقدم حصص غذائيه شهريه
لاسر معينه
نعم
طيب عدد هذه الاسر عدد الاسر عدد هذه
الاسر في قطاع غزه عدد هذه الاسر التي
تستفيد يعني ان كانت لديك معلومات تلك
التي تستفيد من البرنامج ومن الذي سيتبقى
فيما لو علقت هذه المساعدات
يعني
تقريبا حسب العدد الاشخاص هو 422 الف
تقريبا شخص يستفيد من برنامج غذاء العالمي
كان في الماضي وكان هناك تقليص خلال الشهر
الماضي 37 الف شخص تم تقليصهم الان امام
مرحله خطيره بتقليص 200 الف شخص من
المستفيدين وايضا مره اخرى معظمهم من قطاع
غزه الذي يعاني جرات الداعيه هذا الحصار
الاسر بالعشرات الالاف
الاسر التي ستتاثر واليوم شهدنا تظاهره
كبيره في قطاع غزه من هذه الاسر والافراد
وخاصه معظمهم من الاطفال والارامل وغيرهم
من الاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه الذين يعتمدون على
هذه المساعدات البسيطه تقريبا 12 دولار
شهريا يتلقى الشخص ضمن هذه الاسره من هذه
المساعدات وهناك طبعا ما يسمى باسم
مساعدات
الايفاوتشرز القوسائم الشرائيه
الالكترونيه التي يذهب بها
الشخص الذي يتلقى هذه المساعده من اجل
شراء احتياجاته الغذائيه من خلال هذه
القسائم اليوم هذا الامر يهدد واقع هذه
الاسر التي معظمها بدون معين في وضع
اقتصادي جدا صعب هناك تقليص واضح في
المساعدات الانسانيه المقدمه من مختلف
الجهات المانحه نؤكد على اهميه البرنامج
ودوره في تقديم هذه المساعدات ولكن نحن
نحذر من الثلاثه الخطير الخطيره لهذا
القرار فيما يتعلق بتعليق المساعدات بسبب
عدم توفر التمويل وهذه دعوه الان للجهات
الدوليه المختلفه انت ان تقوم بدورها
وتتحمل المسؤولياتها يعني انت تقول انه
مسار تقليص المساعدات هو مسار يعني قديم
وليس
وليد هذه اللحظه او وليد هذا الوقت
بالفعل هناك تراكم للعجز التمويل البرامج
الانسانيه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
وبشكل خاص في قطاع غزه وهذا يترافق ايضا
مع عدم وجود دور سياسي للضغط على دوله
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لرفع الحصار بما يحسن
من الاوضاع الاقتصاديه وتقليل الاعتماديه
على المساعدات اليوم هناك 80% من سكان
قطاع غزه يعتمدون على المساعدات القليله
المقدمه من وكالات اللغاثه المختلفه واؤكد
مره اخرى ان قضيتنا هي ليست قضيه انسانيه
ولكن لها تداعيات هذا الواقع السياسي الذي
نعيش وادي الانتهاكات لا تدايات انسانيه
خطيره على الواقع الذي يعيش كل مواطن في
قطاع غزه وبخاصه نتحدث عن الفئات الاكثر
هشاشه في المجتمع الفلسطيني من نساء من
الاطفال من الاشخاص ذوي اعاقه من مسنين
هؤلاء بحاجه ماسه الى هذه المساعدات وفي
ظل ما شاهدناه ايضا من توقف برنامج
الاتحاد الاوروبي وتقديم المس اعدات
الانسانيه لفتره طويله ايضا هذا التراكم
بشكل طويل رغم استئناف هذا البرنامج ولكن
حتى هذه المبالغ هي لا ترتقي الى المستوى
المطلوب
شكرا
امجد الشوا رئيس شبكه المنظمات الاهليه في
قطاع غزه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
نظم زعماء تحالف الشعب المعارض في تركيا
من مهرجانات انتخابيه في مدينه اسطنبول مع
اقتراض الانتخابات الرئاسيه والتشريعيه
المقرره في الرابع عشر من الشهر الجاري
والقذ زعماء تحالف الشعب المكون من احزاب
الشعب الجمهوري والجيد والمستقبل والسعاده
ودواء والديمقراطي خطابات في حشود قدرها
المراقبون بعشرات الالاف للتصويت لصالح
التحالف خلال الانتخابات المقبله
هذا ودع زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري المعارض
في تركيا كمال كليش دار اوغلو دعم
المواطنين للتصويت لصالح ما وصفه بالحق
والعداله والوقوف في وجه من يهدد
المواطنين حسب تعبيره جاء ذلك خلال كلمه
نلقاها كليشتار اوغلو في حشد جماهري في
مدينه كرش هير وسط البلاد
ستتوجهون الى صناديق الاقتراع وستصوتون
لصالح الحق والعداله ولصالح المواطن
وستقفون في وجه من يتحدث معكم باستعلاء
ومن يهددكم لقد تولوا الحكم لمده 22 عاما
كفى وليتنحوا جانبا لتحقيق التغيير
وليتولى مكانهم انسان عادل لا يغتصب حقوق
العباد
قال الرئيس التركي والمرشح الرئاسي عن
تحالف الجمهور رجب طيب اردوغان انه لا
يمكن ان يكون لدى المعارضه هدف كالحفاظ
على وحدات البلاد وشعبها واتهم اردوغان في
كلمه له خلال مهرجان الانتخابي باسطنبول
اتهم المعارضه بالعمل مع من وصفهم
بالارهابيين ومع من يهدف لضرب اقتصاد
تركيا
لن نسمح الذي يعمل مع التنظيمات الارهابيه
بالتقسيم بلدنا اليست واضحه رسائل من
تعاون مع الارهابيين لنقل حلقه النار
والدماء التي دمرت سوريا الى تركيا وليست
واضحه رسائل من دعم مخططات مستغلي
الاقتصاد ومساعهم في افلاس تركيا
وليست واضحه رسائل من انزعج من الغاز الذي
اكتشفناه في البحر الاسود ومن النفط الذي
اكتشفناه في جبل جابا واسالكم انتم هل
يمكن ان يكون لهؤلاء هدف كالحفاظ على وحده
بلدنا وشعبنا وقوه بلدنا وبقائه
[موسيقى]
عوده الان مشاهدينا الى ملف الحرب الروسيه
علي اوكرانيا فما تصعد انباء عن هجوم
اوكراني مضاد وشيك امرت موسكو باخلاء
جزئيه لمناطق قريبه من خط المواجهه جنوب
اوكرانيا وتواصل روسيا الى قواتها وموالين
لها من بلدات ومناطق في مقاطعتي خرسون
وزبولوجيا بشكل خاص السلطات المواليه
لروسيا في زبولوجيا كانت قد اعلنت الجمعه
ما وصفته باخلاء جزئي لثماني عشره بلده
تسيطر عليها موسكو في المقاطعه ومن بين
المناطق المعنيه بالاجلاء مدينه
انربودار حيث تقع محطه زابوروجيا النوويه
التي يسيطر عليها الجيش الروسي منذ اذار
مارس من العام الماضي وهي اكبر محطه نوويه
في اوكرانيا وفي اوروبا
عمده
الاوكراني في مقاطعه زابوروجيا ايفان
قال ان هناك نزوحا جماعيا للروس من خرسون
وزابروجيا نحو شبه جزيره القرم التي ضمتها
روسيا عام
2014 لكن الوضع هناك لا يبدو افضل ففي وقت
سابق اعلن السلطات القرن المواليه لروسيا
تفعيل منظومه الدفاع الجوي في شمال شبه
الجزيره دون ان تحدد طبيعه الاجسام التي
تصدت لها الدفاعات
يعزوا الروس في المقابل قراره اخلاقي
مناطق قريبه من خط الجبهه في الجنوب
الاوكراني الى تكثيف كياذا قصفها لتلك
المناطق
مسؤول ننتقل زبروجيا المعين من قبل موسكو
قال انه تقرر ابعاده الاطفال وذويهم
والمسنين والمرضى بشكل مؤقت عما وصفها
بنيران العدو تكتفي موسكو بالحديث عن
اجلاء مدنيين دون الاشاره الى مغادره قوات
المواليه لها لمناطق يخشى ان تتعرض قريبا
لهجوم اوكرانيا مضاد
عجله تكهنات حول ذلك الهجوم
باخلاء مواقع مجاوره لمحطه زبروجيا
النوويه من اثار مخاوف امنيه بشان سلامتها
المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رافائيل روسيا قال ان الوضع في
المحطه مضطرب بشكل متزايد وانه من المحتمل
ان يكون خطيرا للحديث عن هذه التطورات
والهجوم الاوكرانيه الوشيك المضاد الذي
يحكي عنه معنى العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي من بيروت صيد الياس
هذه الاجراءات اجراءات الاخلاء التي تقوم
بها القوات الروسيه
والموالون لها في مناطق الجنوب الاوكراني
علامه تؤشر برايك
حسن انها تؤشر اولا على اهميه هذه المنطقه
وكان المدنيين هم عائق امام اي عمليات
عسكريه هي تؤشر الى نمط كانت تستعمله
روسيه عبر نقل السكان المدنيين حصل هذا
الامر في خرسون وحصل هذا الامر في مناطق
لسيشانس
وبالتالي تستفيد منها نقل المدنيين الى
الداخل الاوكراني حيث متواجده القوات
الروسيه او نقلها الى الداخل الروسي خاصه
الاطفال هذا الاستفاده الاساسيه وهذا
النمط الشيء الاخر نقلها لانها تعيق
العمليات العسكريه وكانه يحضر في هذه
المنطقه
قتال تاخيري يعني انت تدافع في خط معين
اذا خسرت هذا الخط تتراجع الى خط اخر
ودائما السكان غير الموالون هم عائق امام
القوات الروسيه استعلام استخبارات وعائق
امام اي حركيه عسكريه طيب
لماذا يعني
التقديرات والتوقعات تتحدث عن ان الهجوم
الوشيك المضاد قد يكون من الجنوب يعني
البعض ربما يقول لماذا لا يكون من الشرق
لكن اكثر التوقعات تتحدث عن الجنوب لماذا
برايك
لا يمكن القول ان الهجوم الاوكراني سيكون
هجوما شاملا وكاملا على جبهه تمتد ما
يقارب الالف كيلومتر يعني اليوم المتطلبات
الاستراتيجيه والاهداف الاستراتيجيه
لاوكرانيا هي كبيره جدا مقابل ما تملك من
وسائل وهذا الامر يجبر اوكرانيا على تحديد
الاولويات ودائما الاولويات يجب ان تكون
في نقاط الضعف الروسيه ويجب ان تكون
مفاجئه وهذا الامر لم يعني عامل المفاجاه
يغيب اليوم وليس كما حصل في خركاب او حصل
في خرسون سابقا فاذا نحن امام الجبهه
الاقل دفاعا
يتم الحديث عن كوبيانسك
يتم الحديث عن الجنوب وهنا ياتي موضوع نقل
السكان المدنيين او حتى يمكن بعد عبور
القوات الاوكرانيه الى الجبهه الشرقيه في
نهر خرسان لنهر وفي خرسان قد يكون هذا كما
يقال فكاي الكماشه ولكن يجب ان يكون هناك
هدف مهم يحقق كي يقال انها انه انجاز
لاوكرانيا لان يعني اتينا على ذكر عامل
المفاجاه فعلا المفقود اليوم في في هجوم
الوشيك ولكن لماذا برايك وخصوصا انه ليس
فقط عامل المفاجاه حتى الاسلحه التي
ستستخدم الاسلحه الجديده على ما يتدرب
الاوكرانيون كل ذلك اصبح متاحا للاعلام
اين خصوصيه هذا الهجوم في هذا الجو
خصوصيه هذا الهجوم حسن هي الى اي مدى هناك
جهوزيه لدى اوكرانيا الجيش الاوكراني الى
اي مدى يمكن دمج هذه القوات والاسلحه من
ضمن ما يسمى
بالقتال المشترك او كومبايندز ارم ارمي هل
هي فعلا جاهزه لهذا الموضوع ثلاثه اهم شيء
هو الدفاعات الجويه والذخيره
المدرعات وهنا ياتي دور الدفاعات الجويه
اليوم بالنسبه لروسيا لم يعني لا يزال
السلاح الجوي الروسي انتاج كما يقال يعني
هو سالما سليما
وتقدر القوه الروسيه اكثر من 900 طائره
حربيه و220 قاذفه هل فعلا سيستطيع
الاوكران منع هذه القوات الجويه من
الاستعمال لانه كل هجوم هو بحاجه الى
تغطيه جويه اذا لم يكن هناك دفاعات جويه
فهذا الامر قد يعيق تماما او قد يفشل ما
يسمى او ما يعد له من هجوم عكسيه اوكراني
شكرا جزيلا لك الياس حناء الخبيره العسكري
والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من بيروت
[موسيقى]
للعنف تداعياته هو ثمنه الباهظ دوما
المشهد من الهند التي تعيش على وقع
اضطرابات متصاعده اثر اشتباكات عرقيه في
شمال الشرقي البلاد ما النتيجه 54 قتيله
فرار نحو 23 الف شخص وحجب السلطات
للانترنت واوامر باطلاق النار في الحالات
القصوى للسيطره على
الارض كيف اشتعل الموقف اساسا جماعه
القبليه احتجت على مطالبه مجموعه التي
تمثل الاغلبيه في ولايه مانيبور باعتراض
الحكومه لها بها ضمن فئه القبيله المجدوله
ويمنح القانون الهندي القبائل التي تندرج
تحت هذا التصنيف حصصا في الوظائف الحكوميه
وفي القبول في الجامعات كاحد اشكال
المبادرات الايجابيه لمعالجه عدم المساواه
الهيكليه والتدريس هكذا تتكرر شراره العنف
وان احتلفت التفاصيل من احتجاج سلمي الى
اللجوء الى السلاح المشكله تتكرر معذيه
روح التسامح والتفاهم بين البشر وسيطرت
اجواء التعصب ايا كان شكرا لكم على حسن
المتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]